at the same time too like again like  let's just like I said make it with me  and you like if you're my girlfriend and  you don't want to sleep with me the the  my first go-to isn't to go try to sleep  with someone else I'm not getting it  from you I would want to explore the  emotional depths of whatever you're  feeling what am I not doing why do you  not want to be close to me I want to be  intimate with you but you're thinking  like a woman and that that's how a woman  right right but like like men it's just  come out you know how guys are like I'm  sure you you especially like like being  as beautiful as you are like most guys  if you put yourself on a platter in  front of them would be down yeah yeah  yeah